ام
اهلا بكم صرح الرئيس الايراني حسن روحاني
بان بلاده لن تسعى في اي ظرف كان الى
حيازه اسلحه دمار شامل بما في ذلك السلاح
النووي واكد ان حكومته لديها السلطه
الكامله للتفاوض على اتفاق نووي مع الغرب
نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في محورين
هل من جديد في تصريحات الرئيس الايراني
بشان برنامج بلاده النووي
ما هي حدود صلاحيات حكومته في التفاوض مع
الغرب ومدى تاثر المفاوضات المقبله
بالظروف الاقليميه والدوليه الراهنه
الافعال اكثر اهميه من الاقوال هكذا رد
الامريكيون على تصريحات الرئيس الايراني
لمحطه ام بي سي الامريكيه واكد المتحدث
باسم البيت الابيض استعداد الرئيس باراك
اوباما بخوض مفاوضات ثنائيه مباشره مع
ايران اذا اظهرت جديه في التخلي عن
برنامجها لانتاج اسلحه نوويه
ياتي هذا فيما توالت خلال الايام الماضيه
تصريحات ايرانيه متفائله ازاء امكانيه حل
الخلاف النووي مع الغرب وقد صرح مرشد
الجمهوريه الايرانيه علي خامنئي مجددا بان
بلاده ترفض السلاح النووي اطل انطلاقا من
عقيدتها ومبادئها الاسلاميه
الى اين يتجه الملف النووي الايراني الذي
طالما اثارت تعقيدات ه كثيرا من الجدل
خلال السنوات الماضيه السؤال يطرح بشده
بعد تصريحات الرئيس الايراني حسن روحاني
الاخيره عبر تلفزيون ام بي سي الامريكي
والتي قال فيها ان بلاده لا تسعى ل حيازه
اسلحه دمار شامل بما في ذلك السلاح النووي
وانها لا تسعى للحرب مع ايه دوله وان ما
تتمناه ايران للمنطقه حسب تصريحاته هو
الحكم باراده الشعب هل هي لغه جديده يمكن
ان تشكل نقله ايرانيه في اداره ملف البلاد
النووي خاصه وان اي مفاوضات مرتقبه تخيم
عليها طلبيات الثقه المفقوده المتجدره
بينها والغرب منذ سنوات تصريحات الرئيس
روحاني جاءت في وقت تستعد فيه ايران نفسها
لمثل تلك المفاوضات واعادت حكومتها في
فريق التفاوض ونقلت الاشراف على الملف من
مجلس الامن القومي ووزاره الخارجيه
وذكر رئيس منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه
بوعد قطع قبل الانتخابات الرئاسيه بان
الايرانيين على موعد مع انفراج في الملف
النووي خلال هذا العام وتزامن التصريحات
روح ان ايضا مع ما ذكره البيت الابيض ان
الرئيس باراك اوباما ابلغ روحاني تم
لواشنطن من طول الوقت الذي استغرقه النزاع
مع ايران واستعدادها لح له ولكن بطريقه
تسمح لطهران باظهار ان برنامجها النووي
مخصصه فقط للاغراض السلميه
لم تقرا اي تطورات خاصه بايران وال ملفها
النووي لم عزم عن الظروف الاقليميه
والدوليه الراهنه
وعن احتمالات ان تكون ايران حولت من
مواقفها لخدمه مصالحها وربما لطرح واقع
جديد قبيل اي مفاوضات قادمه وفي الذهن
تاثير حجم العقوبات الدوليه المفروضه
عليها والمتجدده منذ سنوات هلا بحث ايران
مستعده لقبول تجميد تخصيبها اليورانيوم
لنسبه تطال الغرب وهل سيستمر الغرب لها
الان باذن جديده ثم ما هي حدود صلاحيات
الرئيس روحاني وحكومته المتعلقه بهذا
الملف وقد كان القول الفصل فيه دائما
للمرشد الاعلى للجمهوريه علي قابلين
موضوع حلقه الراقصه مع ضيفي من طهران محمد
صالح صدقيان مدير المركز العربي للدراسات
الايرانيه ومن واشنطن ريتشارد كبير
الباحثين في محادثات شون اهلا بضيفه وابدا
بضيفي منطقه السيد محمد اه محمد صالح
صدقيان
ما الذي تطور ما الذي اختلف حتى يمكن
الحديث عن اه تفاوض يمكن البناء عليه
اه بسم الله الرحمان الرحيم ان يعتقد بان
ال اه الظروف التي تتمتع بها ايران حاليا
تختلف كثيرا عما كانت عليه خلال السنوات
السابقه وبالتالي عندما كان الايرانيون
يتحدثون اللغه مع المسؤولين الامريكيين
كان ينظرون الان ثانيا ت والظروف التي تمر
بها ايران الان ايران متقدم في جميع
المجالات في المجال الصناعي في المجال
العسكري في المجال الامني ايضا وهذه
القدره الايرانيه الجديده التي الموجوده
حاليا لدى اه لدى طهران هي التي دعت
القياده الايرانيه وبشخص مرشد الجمهوريه
ايه الله علي خامنئي ان يعطي الضوء الاخضر
من اجل التفاوض وحتى
الولايات المتحده
ان يعتقد بان الظروف الان تغيرت كثيرا
اولا شخص الرئيس يختلف بالنسبه الى اه ال
المرشد الايراني الاعلى يطلع علي خامنئي
اه ال السيد روحاني يجب علينا ان نتذكر
بان الرئيس حسن روحاني هو كان ممثلا
ومندوب القائد في مجلس الامن القومي لمده
ثمان سنوات اه كان ممثلو ايضا لمده سته
عشر عاما عندما كان امينا لمجلس الامن
القومي وبالتالي هناك علاقه ربما ترجع الى
اه قبل انتصار الثوره الاسلاميه بين
الرجلين وهو يعرف حسن روحاني بشكل جيد
وهذه الصلاحيات الجديده الممنوحه للرئيس
حتى الروحاني اه ربما هي تعكس مدى ثقه
المرشد بالرئيس حسن روحاني اه ب بالشكل
التي تختلف اه لا عند عند الرئيس السابق
محمود احمدي نجاد ولا حتى عند الرئيس
الاسبق محمد خاتمي وبالتالي يعني اعتقد
بان هناك نوع من الثقه المتبادله بين
الرجلين هي التي استطاعت ان تعطي الضوء
الاخضر من قبل المرشد لحسن روحاني لان
يصرح بمثل هذه التصريحات
صلاحيات كامله من اجل حل الملف النووي سيد
هل تعتقد باننا نحن امام ظروف جديده في
ايران وفي المنطقه ام نحن امام مناوره
جديده كما تقول بعض الاطراف الاقليميه
وخاصه ان اسرائيل
لكن ان نعرف حقا ما هو الدافع
وراى ما جرى هناك اسباب تجعلنا ان نجادل
في الاتجاهين بالفعل هناك وضع من جديد
وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالتطورات والمستجدات في
سوريا وهي حليف وثيق لايران
والان هي في طور تخليها عن اسلحه الدمار
الشامل لديها وهناك رئيس لدينا
لديه لحل مختلف ونمط مختلف عن احمدي نجاد
اذا فهذا يبعث على الامل كما انه يمتلك
قدرا كبيرا من المعرفه عن الغرب واذا ما
كان بامكانه ان يفهم كيفيه التوصل الى
اتفاقيه مع الغرب اذا ما كان يرغب بفعل
ذلك ف ستتقدم الامور ام الامن في ايران
رغم ما يجري في سوريا على الارجح انه تقوى
فيما يخص
سحب القوات الامريكيه من العراق ومن
افغانستان وبالتركيز الامريكي الجديد على
اسيا اذن ليس هناك حاجه بالتالي لردع
لبرنامج ايران النووي على المدى القصير من
ناحيه اخرى وعلى المدى البعيد هناك قوى
داخل ايران
تود ان تحصل على خيار السلاح ان النووي
حتى لو كان الرئيس الحالي والمرشد الاعلى
الحالي لا يريدون ذلك ف ايران تمتلك
القدرات على الحصول على السلاح النووي في
المستقبل انت وانا واخرون قد يمكن ان نرى
لماذا يمكن لايران او لماذا تريد انا
الحصول على السلاح النووي
وخاصه ان هناك روسيا والصين
واسرائيل يقال بان لديها اسلحه نوويه وهي
قريبه من ايران
اذن اه الاسرائيليين والامريكيين قد
يقومون ب تحرك عسكري
ولذلك فان عامل الردع لدى ايران قد يمنع
ذلك واذا ما اردت ان اه على سبيل المثال
ان تشارك ب عمل عدائي ضد بعض دول الخليج
من جيرانها
وقد يكون هذا العمل الرضى الايراني لصالحه
اذا يمكن ان نجادل في الاتجاهين ولكن نقول
ان الاراده الاداره الحاليه صادقه املا في
نواياها لا ندري ولكن علينا ان نتعامل مع
الاداره الحاليه بالنظر الى الادارات
السابقه السيد محمد صالح الموقف الايراني
معروف لا نسعى الى امتلاك سلاح نووي ولكن
من حقنا ان تكون لنا التقنيه النوويه
السلميه
موقف الدول الغربيه واضح فيما يتعلق بهذه
المساله اذن ما الذي اختلف الان فيما
يتعلق بالموقف الايراني حيال الحديث عن اي
تقدم قد يكون في تفاوضها مع الدول الغربيه
وخاصه ال واشنطن
يعني انا اعتقد بان كلام الرئيس روحاني
حول عدم رغبه ايران في ان في انتاج او
امتلاك القنبله الذريه هذا ليس بجديد
اه مرشد الجمهوريه ايه الله علي خامنئي له
بفتوى دينيه شرعيه ملزمه له ولغيره بعدم
اقتناء وامتلاك و انتاج السلاح النووي
لكن يبدو بان الدول الغربيه وتحديدا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تريد ان
تصدق مثل هذه
الفتاوى او المواقف الرسميه الايرانيه
الان يبدو بانها لديها رغبه في ان تصدق
مثل ذلك حسب ما وردت المعلومات بان الرئيس
باراك اوباما طلب من الرئيس روحاني ان
يعلن ذلك بشكل واضح وهو ما ادلى به الى
القناه التلفزيونيه
الامريكيه عندما قال بان ايران لا تريد لا
في هذا الوقت ولا مستقبلا اقتناء السلاح
النووي وهي لا تدخل هذا السلاح في
منظومتها
الاستراتيجيه العسكريه اه ان يعتقد بان
الولايات المتحده
ويعين اسرائيل
ما الذي اختلف الان موقف طهران معروف
وموقف الدول الغربيه معروف ما الذي اختلف
الان حتى يجعل الحديث عن تفاوض بنفس جديد
امر ممكن
انا اعتقد بان هناك عاملين عامل يتعلق
بايران وعمل يتعلق بالولايات المتحده
العمل الذي يتعلق بايران هو انه هناك خطاب
جديد فعلا من قبل الرئيس حسن روحاني يختلف
كثيرا عن الخطاب الذي كان عند الرئيس
محمود احمدي نجاد حيث امتاز الرئيس احمدي
نجاد بالتشدد كثيرا حيال الدول الغربيه
حيال الملف النووي حيال الملفات الاقليميه
بشكل عام وحتى الملفات الدوليه الان هناك
نحن نتحدث امام اه عن خطاب سياسي معتدل
ياخذ بنظر الاعتبار
متطلبات ومصالح اه ايران ومتطلبات الدول
الاقليميه وحتى متطلبات ومصالح الدول
الغربيه وبالتالي هذا الخطاب الجديد ربما
انعكس وساهم في مثل هذه التطورات العمل
الذي يرتبط بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه
يبدو لي بان الرئيس باراك اوباما هو اولا
اه قال منذ اه ال الحملات الانتخابيه قال
هو مستعد حتى ان يذهب الى ايران من اجل حل
المشكله مع ايران لم يتمكن من ذلك بسبب اه
ال اه سياسه المحافظين الجدد واللوبي
الاسرائيلي الذي يضغط على الاداره
الامريكيه الان يبدو بان التطورات
الاقليميه سواء كان في سوريا او في العراق
او في افغانستان حاجه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى دوله قويه والى موقف قوي من
دوله قويه مثل ايران في الشرق الاوسط ان
يعتقد بان هذا التغيير ليس في ايران فحسب
وانما حتى عند الاداره الامريكيه عند
الرئيس باراك اوباما عندما تلتقي المصالح
الامريكيه الايرانيه
اه نحن اه يجب علينا ان نقف الى تطورات
جديده ربما هذا الحديث عن الحوار المباشر
هويدي المصالح المشتركه وايران قالت بشكل
واضح باننا امام
اه اه يعني نحن نريد ان تنفذ المصالح
المشتركه لاحتمال الاحترام المتبادل واؤكد
على نقطه مهمه في غايه الاهميه اذا سمحت
لي خفض اذا كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
تاخذ اه المصالح الاسرائيليه بنظر
الاعتبار وان تنظر العلاقه مع ايران بعين
اسرائيليه انا لا اعتقد بانه هناك تقدم
سوف يحصل على صعيد العلاقه الامريكيه
الايرانيه
لكن اذا ارادت ان تاخذ مصالح الدول
الاقليميه بنظر
ان تترك المصالح الاسرائيليه لكن المصالح
الاقليميه وبالذات المصالح الايرانيه ان
تقضي بان ذلك يصب في مصلحه البلد السيد
هناك من يربط بين اه ما جرى بالملف
الكيميائي في سوريا الحديث عن اتفاق عن
المبادره الروسيه والدور الروسي وعن ما
خلفه من مؤشرات في طهران تعلق بملفها
النووي هل ترى من رابط بين ما جرى فيما
يتعلق بالملف الكيميائي في سوريا وبين
الملف النووي في ايران
في الحقيقه ان ما يجري في سوريا لافت
للانتباه من حيث انه تقليديا
سوريا ومصر رفضت التوقيع على معاهده حظر
الاسلحه الكيماويه وجد لهما كان بانهما
بحاجه الى الخيار او الامكانيه بامتلاك
هذا النوع من اسلحه الدمار الشامل
لانه قالت بان اسرائيل تمتلك هذه الاسلحه
واسرائيل رفضت التوقيع على
اتفاقيه منع الانتشار قطع الصوتيه
وقالتا بانهما ستتخلى ان عن اسلحتهم ا اذا
ما تخلت اسرائيل عن
اسلحتها النوويه المفترضه وانضمت الى
معاهده منع انتشار الاسلحه
وكانت هناك منطقه خاليه من الاسلحه
النوويه في الشرق الاوسط ولكن نقول رغم
المحادثه على مدى عامين كان هناك عرقله
بسبب الربيع العربي بالنسبه الاسره الى
الان سوريا تخلت او تقول بانها تتخلى الان
عن اسلحه الدمار الشامل وانها لا تطالب
اسرائيل بفعل اي شيء
ازاء هذا التحرك اذن هذا ايضا قد يكون
نموذجا لايران يحذوهم ايران تعيد تاكيد
لعل نيتها على ان لا تمتلك اسلحه نوويه او
اسلحه دمار شامل اخرى وان تضع جانبا
القضيه الاسرائيليه كما حدث في السابق اذن
هذا يجعل الامر يمكن تخيله عندما تقوم
الحكومه الايرانيه الان بالقول بانها لا
تحتاج او لا تريد اسلحه نوويه لانه ان لم
تهاجم من قبل دوله اجنبيه فليس عندها
الحاجه لان تمتلك رادعا في الجزء من هذه
الحلقه سوف نتناول هل يملك الرئيس
الايراني اوراق كل اوراق الملف النووي
التي كانت في يد المشرفه ماذا عن العامل
الاقليمي فيما يتعلق باي تطور قد يفهم من
خلال هذه التصريحات للرئيس الايراني وردود
فعل من الغرب بعد الفاصل
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه التي
تناقش دلالات تصريح الرئيس الايراني بان
بلاده لن تطور ابدا اسلحه نوويه بانه يملك
صلاحيات كامله للتفاوض مع الغرب ووجه
التحيه ضيفي في واشنطن وكذلك في اه سيد
محمد اه صالح صدقيان
الى اي مدى فعلا الان الرئيس الايراني
يملك كل اوراق الملف انه وبالتالي يعرف
متى واين يتوقف فيما يتعلق بالملف النووي
الايراني
يعني منذ ان اه امر الرئيس روحاني بترحيل
او بنقل ملف المفاوضات من مجلس الامن
القومي الايراني الى وزاره الخارجيه
وتشكيل اه
فرقه عمل من اجل وضع سياسه
المفاوضات النوويه مع مجموعه خمسه زائد
واحد او مع الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اه المعلومات او المصادر تتحدث عن صلاحيات
كبيره اعطاها مرشد الجمهوريه الى الرئيس
حسن روحاني وهو يمتلك هذه الصلاحيات وهناك
اعتقاد من قبل جميع المسؤولين او كبار
المسؤولين الايرانيين بان الرئيس حسن
روحاني يعتبر من الكفاءات التي اه اه
واكبت ال اه المفاوضات النوويه اه منذ عام
الف وتسعمائه وهو يملك القرار
نتذكر
اه ان يعتقد بان هناك خطوط عريضه حصل
عليها من المرشد وبالتالي هو يتحرك في
اطار هذه الخطوط العريضه لكن لا يمنع ان
اه ان يتباحث مع المرشد هو باعتباره رئيس
مجلس الامن القومي
اه هذا المجلس يضم ايضا اه اثنان من
مندوبيه المرشد يعينهم دائما ل اه في في
في هذا المجلس ينقلون توصيات المرشد
وبالتالي ان يعتقد بان الظروف الحاليه
والصلاحيات التي يتمتع بها الرئيس حسن
روحاني تختلف كثيرا جدا عن ما كانت بيد
الرئيس احمدي نجاد او بيد الرئيس محمد ان
في عهدي الرئيسين خاتمي واحمدي نجاد كانت
هناك مفاوضات نوويه مع مجموعه خمسه زائد
واحد لكن يعتقد بان الظروف الحاليه تختلف
كليا وجذريا مع عهد الرئيسين خاتمي واحمدي
نجاد بناءا على هذه الصلاحيات التي منحت
له من اجل قياده المفاوضات النوويه مع
مجموعه خمسه زائد واحد او مع الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
وهو ما انعكس على التفاؤل الذي ابداه مدير
منظمه الطاقه النوويه الايرانيه الدكتور
علي اكبر صالحي عندما يتحدث صالحي عن
تفاؤل على في الملف النووي وفي المفاوضات
اه اعتقد بانه يعني ما يقول لانه هو كان
وزير الخارجيه والان هو جزء من الفريق
المفاوض في المجال السيد واعتقد بان روسيا
بامكانها ان تلعب دور اكبر فيما يتعلق باي
التفاوض بين ايران والدول الغربيه بالنظر
الى ما جرى في المبادره الروسيه المتعلقه
بالملف الكبرى في سوريا
انه ممكن نعم روسيا ولوقت طويل حاولت ان
تقوم بدور اساسي في المفاوضات
روسيا اخذت دور البلدين على سبيل المثال
في محاوله ربط دعمها فيما يتعلق بمفاعلين
شهران النووي الى اتفاقيه نوويه بان لا
يكون هناك عمليه التخصيب او انتاج الوقود
انه يقال لا تقلقوا سنقدم لكم المقود
لمحاربه لذلك ليش كمان تبني واحد ولذلك
هذا منع ايران من ان تمتلك القدرات لكي
تحصل على المواد الانشطاريه
ولكن الحكومه الايرانيه
اخرت على بحقها في التخصيب ولذلك المبادره
الروسيه فشلت ولكن رجع ايضا اطلقت مبادره
السابق ولكن المشكله تتمثل في ان روسيا
ليس لديها تقل نوع من يفوز على ايران كما
لديها ذاك النفوذ وعلى سوريا وايران
تقليديه تسير في سياسات
منفصله ومستقله عن اي قوى اخرى وهي قد
واجهت ضغوطا من اوروبا والولايات المتحده
وعندما يحصل ذلك كل مره يكون هناك مقاومه
من ايران ذاك الامر ينطبق على روسيا ومع
ذلك اعتقد ان الصينيين لن يحاولوا انهم
يعرفون بان ذات المشكله اذا في حقا الروس
يمكن ان يساعدوا في الخوض في عمليه الكبير
ولكن اعتقد ان هذا ليس ضروريا واذا ما
كانت الحكومه الايرانيه تريد ان تتوصل الى
صفقه واتفاقيه مع الغرب وليس هناك ما يمنع
الروس من ان يشاركوا بشكل مباشر بالاضافه
الى مشاركتهم في
اشكرك الخمس زائد واحد طيب سيد محمد صالح
صدقيان
عندما نتكلم على اي صفقه وفق اي قاعده
وهنا دعني انقل لك ما نقلته بعض الصحف
الاسرائيليه عن ما يقال بان تل ابيب ابلغت
به واشنطن في حال لقاء الرئيس الامريكي
بالرئيس الايراني قالت يجب ان يستند
التفاوض على اربعه شروط اولها الوقفه
الكلى ل اعمال تخصيب اليورانيوم ثانيا
اخراج كل اليورانيوم المخصب من ايران
ثالثا اغلاق منشات التخصيب والشرطه الرابع
هو وقف مسار عمليات التخصيب من
البلوتونيوم كيف تعلق على هذه الاشتراطات
الاسرائيليه في مجال الحديث عن اي تطور في
هذا الملف يعني
يعني اركز على نقطه في غايه الاهميه هناك
ثقه المفقوده بين ايران والولايات المتحده
وبين ايران والدول الغربيه وبالتالي هذه
الثقه المفقوده هي التي تقف حائلا دون
تقدم اي مباحثات سواء كان في اطار مجموعه
خمسه زائد واحد او مع الوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه
اذا ما تمكن البلد ان ايران والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه من تعزيز الثقه لان
الثقه هذه شيء في غايه الاهميه ايران
عندما
لجات الى تخصيب مرتفع لليورانيوم يصل الى
العشرين بالمائه هو كان بسبب عدم ثقتها من
الدول الغربيه التي تريد ان تعطيها هي
طلبت من الدول الغربيه ان تعطيها اه
يورانيوم مخصب او الواحد
نوويه بتخصيب عشرين بالمائه لكنها امتنعت
عن ذلك بسبب ضغوط اسرائيليه مارستها على
الولايات المتحده وعلى الدول الغربيه الان
ايران لا تريد ان تنتج عشرين بالمائه من
التخصيب هي تريد ان تكتفي باقل من خمسه
بالمائه وهذه اقل من خمسه بالمائه اه
تعتبر لا شيء لا يمكن ان تنتج سلاح نووي ب
اي ظرف من الظروف
لكن اه اه هذه الثقه المفقوده هي المهم
اذا تحققت هذه الثقه عندها يمكن الحديث عن
كل الامور يعني لا توجد هناك مشكله مع
الوكاله الدوليه لا توجد هناك مشكله مع
القوانين والمواثيق الدوليه ايران موقعه
على
معاهده الان بي تي اسرائيل لم توقع على
ذلك ايران عضو في مجلس الامن في الوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
اه اسرائيل ليست ليست عضو في ذلك ايران
دوليه اسرائيل
نعم ان يعتقد بانه يجب على الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ان تستغل هذه الفرصه
وان لا تنظر بعين اسرائيليه الى ايران
وعند ذلك تستطيع ان تحقق كل شيء في قضايا
التخصيب ان يعتقد بانها قابله للحل
عندما هددت واشنطن بتنفيذ عمليه عسكريه في
سوريا قالت الامر لا يتعلق فقط سوريا
وانما يتعداه الى الملف النووي في ايران
وكذلك حزب الله ب هذه التطورات هل الرساله
وصلت ام نحن امام رئيس جديد في ايران له
وجهه نظر مختلفه وبالتالي يجب عدم الربط
في
من التفكير انه اذا كان الرئيس اوباما
استمر بالحديث عن هذه الخطوط الحمراء الخط
الاحمر لايران لا تخصيب اليورانيوم بنسبه
عشرين في المائه لكوريا الشماليه لا تقوم
ب تجربه صاروخ طويل المدى ولسوريا الخط
الاحمر كان لا تستخدمي ولا تمتلك السلاح
الكيماوي الخوف انه لا احد كان ينظر الى
هذه البيانات التصريحات الامريكيه بجديه
وهذا ادى باليابان والسعوديه واسرائيل ان
تعبر مخاوف عن مصداقيه يا سيدي الدفاع
عنها ادركنا الوقت سيد ريتشاردز كبير
الباحثين في معهد وكذلك اشكر ضيفي من
طهران محمد صالح صدقيان مدير المركز
العربي للدراسات الايرانيه
الى اللقاء
نعم